Part B for X is not equal to zero
express f prime of X is a piecewise
defined function find the value of x for
which f prime of x is equal to negative
three so the first thing you might be
wondering is why did we even have to
take out X is equal to zero from there
or why do why is the derivative not
going to be defined there and that's
just because you're going to see that
the derivative is going to be something
different when we approach X is equal to
zero from the left vs. when we approach
X is equal to zero from the right and
that's why they just took it out of
there for us but let's just figure out
what that derivative is for all the
other values of X so f prime of X is
equal to so for X is less than zero
we're going to take the derivative of
this first case so the derivative of 1
is just 0 the derivative of negative 2
sine of X will derivative sine of X is
just cosine of X it's just going to be
negative 2 cosine of X negative 2 cosine
of X 4 for X is less than 0 and then for
X is a greater than 0 I'll do this in
another color I'll do it in orange we
have this case right over here and we'll
just do the chain rule derivative of
negative 4x with respect to X is
negative 4 and derivative of e to the
negative 4x with respect to e with the
derivative of e to the negative 4x with
respect to negative 4 X is just e to the
negative 4x e to the negative 4x
sometimes you could say this is
derivative of the inside times the
derivative of the outside with respect
to the inside so either way it's
negative 4 e to the negative 4x 4x is
greater than 0 so we did the first part
we expressed F prime of X as a piecewise
defined function it's not we didn't
define the derivative actually I forgot
a parenthesis here we did interrupt we
didn't define the derivative when X is
equal to 0 because it's actually not
going to be defined there now let's do
the second part find the value of x for
which F prime of X is equal to negative
3 and so if this wasn't piecewise
defined you just very simply just say
look you know f prime of X is equal to
negative 3 you would take whatever f
prime of X is equal to and you do some
algebra to solve for it but here you're
like well which
- I didn't use I don't know if the X
that gets us to negative 3 is gonna be
less than 0 or I don't know if it's
gonna be greater than 0 so I don't know
which case to use and one thing that
they realize is is to look at these
functions a little bit and realize that
cosine of X is a bounded function cosine
of X can only go between positive 1 and
negative 1 so negative 2 cosine of X can
only go between positive 2 and negative
2 so this can only go between positive 2
and negative 2 so it can never get to
negative 3 so if anything's ever going
to get to negative 3 it's going to have
to be this part of the derivative or
this part of the derivative definition
so it's going to have to be this thing
right over here and hopefully there's
some values of X greater than 0 where
this thing right over here is equal to
negative 3 so let's try it out negative
4 e to the negative 4x needs to be equal
to negative 3 we can divide both sides
by negative 4 we get e to the negative
4x is equal to negative 3 fourths
divided by negative 4 is 3/4 we can take
the natural log of both sides and we
will get negative 4 X is equal to the
natural log of 3/4 natural log of 3/4
and just to be clear what I did here I
mean you literally could put the natural
log here natural log there and you could
put the natural log there as well to see
that step the natural this is saying
what power what power would have to
raise e to to get e to the negative 4x
well obviously I need to raise e to the
just the negative 4x spot over there so
this this power is negative 4x and then
we just took the natural log of the
right-hand side as well and then to
solve for x we can divide both sides by
negative 4 so you get X is equal to or
we could say we could multiply both
sides by negative 1/4 either way
negative 1/4 natural log of 3/4 and what
we need to do is verify that this X so
we used this case right over here we
used that case but we have to make sure
that this X that we that we can use this
case that this X is greater than 0 and
we might be tempted right when we look
at this is a way way this looks like a
negative number but we have to remind
ourselves
the natural log of 3/4 since 3/4 is less
than e the natural log of 3/4 is going
to be a negative number is going to be e
to some negative exponent so since this
is negative and and this part right over
here is negative so that is also
negative you have a negative times a
negative so this right over here is
going to be positive so this is a
positive value right over here so you
would use you would use you would use
this case right over here so that's our
answer X is equal to negative 1/4
natural log of 3/4 or the derivative we
could write F prime of negative 1/4
times the natural log of 3/4 is equal to
is equal to negative 3 and we're done